fue una figura destacada de la
Administración Trump Nicky Haley fue
designada a embajador ante Naciones
Unidas por el anterior presidente
crítica de Trump convertida en colega es
notoriamente conocida por sus cambios de
opinión
no pretenderé ser la mayor porrisa del
presidente electo
heilia cortó su segundo mandato como
gobernadora de Carolina del Sur para
unirse al equipo de Trump a los 44 años
se convirtió en la primera mujer y
primera persona procedente de una
minoría que gobernaba en ese estado
Haley quedó en el foco de la atención
nacional en 2015 después se quedó un
supremacista blanco matara nueve
personas en una iglesia de charleston un
evento que la impulsó a presionar para
retirar la controvertida bandera
confederada de la legislatura estatal
Haley fue la primera mujer miembro de la
Administración Trump apoyó su decisión
de retirarse del Consejo de derechos
humanos de la ONU abandonar el acuerdo
climático de París cortar el
financiamiento a los refugiados
palestinos y salirse del acuerdo nuclear
con Irán
aquí hay evidencia concreta de La
proliferación ilegal de armas iraníes
desde que abandonó el gobierno de Trump
en 2019 Haley regresó a Carolina del Sur
y escribió dos libros en 2021 anunció
que no consideraría una candidatura a la
Casa Blanca si el presidente Trump se
postulaba una declaración que pareciera
estar lista para revertir no creo que
sea necesario tener 80 años para ser
líder en Washington creo que necesitamos
una generación joven que entre de un
paso al frente si me postulo lo hago
contra Joe biden si bien la mayoría de
las encuestas nacionales muestran a
Nicky Haley con un solo dígito tiene un
récord de victorias en carreras
difíciles se obtiene el boleto
republicano será la primera mujer y la
primera persona de una minoría étnica en
hacerlo